often as an introvert you just set a  very high bar for yourself in order to  talk right so you feel like in order for  you to have the permission to talk the  thing that you want to say needs to be  insanely valuable and if this what you  want to say is not very valuable then  you don't really have the right to talk  and in order to overcome this of course  the obvious thing is to to lower the bar  a little bit often you're very much  underestimating the actual value of the  things that you want to contribute so  maybe you feel like a thought that you  have is obvious to everyone else which  is why you don't need to share it but  very often the truth is that this  thought that you're having is not at all  obvious which is why many more things  very likely are worth to be shared